uh hi all uh this is krishna here today
we will be looking upon uh
the basic introduction to azure platform
and uh no why
we need to i mean like why we can opt to
go to one of the leading service
provider and uh simultaneously i would
be actually showing you a very small
demo from the azure platform
and uh
then we will be looking up on you know
if you have any questions let us
actually discuss on the same okay before
we end
so uh
again uh just one is that now
we just need to know uh
why
what is cloud computing now so it is uh
simply put together
uh it is an outsourcing of the computing
services
or in other words i would say it's an
i.t outsourcing
or for simply uh you know
another simple thing we are just using
someone else computers or someone else
application
okay and we are paying for it
uh okay and as far as john mccarthy in
1960s it says like computation may
someday be organized as a public utility
and right now yes uh with that cloud
computing in picture
uh we are using it as an public utility
where in which we pay for what we are
using
um again we will be looking on that same
okay
so uh
after that we will see you know for any
cloud computing uh we have the five
essential characteristics of it
uh which one of their on-demand
self-service your broader network access
the resource pooling your rapid
elasticity and the measured service
so with that measured service uh we will
be able to
go ahead and you know
one of the things of the cloud computing
paper use so that will be coming up from
our measured services so on demand uh
you know we could actually
access
any computing of capabilities from
anywhere
with only an
access to a internet browser
all right and
we can actually what we need from uh
from from the technicality or from that
cloud service provider
and uh the broader network access this
can be accessed through
any platform irrespective of uh you know
you are logged in uh to
a desktop your laptop your mobiles okay
because we do we do have some apps uh
that have been uh created from the cloud
service providers and uh basically uh
much of the apps
as of now uh i just use them for
monitoring purposes so the real-time
monitoring that can be done from my
mobile and apart from that uh for me to
access uh we have that portal and that
portals can be accessed via your theme
clients your tablets your pc your
desktop
as long as you have a device that is
compatible uh you know where we can
actually have a browser and uh connected
to the internet
and uh the resource pooling one of the
characteristics again uh
which can actually
serve multiple computers all right
because all the resources in the backend
or in the infrastructure end has been
pooled
all right and then uh we have the rapid
elasticity all right and in there we can
actually go ahead and automatically
scale your environment
okay at any given point of time
uh you can scale your environment um up
or you can you can actually increase the
resources get the resources i mean you
take any type of service it can be
uh provided in just a couple of minutes
and after that you know
it's just a matter of
minutes and
responses again on the changing
requirements it can be easily managed
and uh as i told you the measured
services uh
here we would be seeing like
again one of the major characteristics
and one of the very good reasons uh for
companies to choose uh the cloud
computing sector that is uh the paper
used so
here everything is monitored
your cpu utilizations memory utilization
your uh i'm speaking about the different
services and after that
everything which has been monitored
metered build and we will only pay for
what we use so again this is one of the
essential characteristics of the cloud
computing
so uh let us quickly see on
what uh you know the cloud computing or
the different platforms what we have
so the different platforms what we see
are your infrastructure as a service
where we host
uh any of the services i mean you take
up some computing power
and your platform as a service uh
again it is creating your application
interface or your
or your you know a platform for us to
develop your code deployments
okay so that is your platform as a
service and you have our
software as a service
all right and
the software as a service where we
consume so we will not have an option to
make any changes into the softwares so
by default we have office 365 from
microsoft
so again these are the common three
pillars of the cloud computing
one good reason is uh why we need to use
the cloud
okay
so a couple of reasons first thing is
it's very speed i mean
whenever we say the initial deployment
or you know your deployments are always
faster
and then uh
you can actually scale
at any given point of time the auto
scaling what we have
and then uh you know the lower costs
because you only pay for what is needed
so we are not going to spend more amount
and again on the azure platform uh we
have a different pricing structure now
that is good for
any sort of a company so we will be
discussing on that one on the other uh
pricing
all right so again uh one of the major
benefits of using the cloud is the speed
the scalabilities and the
savings or the benefits that we get
right now why we need to use azure
already we have like so many public
cloud service providers in the market
what is the reason for us to go with the
azure platform
so whenever we say uh azure
it's an open and a flexible cloud
platform and you can use or extend your
existing it infrastructure
so this is the concept of building your
hybrid cloud model
okay and along with that we have scale
as you need and pay as you go
and also azure government which is
recently released from azure right now
so they have uh the azure government is
the data centers which are located in
the united states so that uh you know
for the compliance issues and the
regulations what we have so the iso
government is basically released
to serve the government sectors
okay and uh it is a new launch of azure
and right now it is only in the united
states
and one of the other features what we
have is you can run your apps from
anywhere
all right and again uh
as we speak the essentials of what we
have okay and the five characteristics
what we see
uh everything has been met
you are paying as per your use okay and
you can actually access your apps from
any given point of time and any area as
long as you have an internet
okay
so uh as of now uh we do see that uh
more than 66 percent of the fortune 500
companies
uh they are relying on the azure
platform
all right and
let us go going forward uh we would be
seeing
where are the data centers located for
the azure
and uh
as per today's statistical data we have
like uh uh the google i'm sorry um
azus data centers are spread across in
22 regions
and
it has a planning for you know it has
already announced
eight additional regions
and uh one of the major question like
you know why do we need these many data
centers across the globe
so one of the uh
one of the reasons why we
look on a trend where the data centers
are globally
available because to reduce the latency
one of the things on the performance
when we look into it to reduce the
latency of your data retrievals and uh
one of the major concerns what we have
is on the compliances and the security
of it
so every country has a different set of
and you know other compliance and the
regulations
so
they want to attract more number of
people or more number of companies to
start using the cloud okay
so
again uh since the companies are bounded
by some sort of a law
of that regions so some might not easily
migrate to a different data centers
located on a different part of the globe
so for that reason what microsoft has
come up with
uh they have released or they have
actually started their own data centers
across the globe and if you see uh
some of the uh
data centers uh we don't find in uh
india right now i mean from
a couple of public uh cloud service
providers but azure has uh you know a
couple of uh data centers which have
already been released
and uh
uh the things have been changing on how
the contracts are being done so uh you
have a couple of more information from
that source uh in regents and also
based upon that region uh the services
will actually differ so
every data center and microsoft azure
services they differ a bit
because uh not all the services are
provided
across all the data centers so uh please
refer to that particular link and uh you
will be receiving uh you know some more
information about uh the services uh
that you get from the different data
centers globally
and uh let us quickly look on what are
the popular products of the azure okay
which are highly being used i would like
there are so many services there are so
many products that we see in the azure
but
always there we are you know some of
them which are highly used and the
popular ones so one of them is your
virtual machines
and azure will actually uh know they
provide you both windows and a
non-windows virtual machines
and with windows you have a
you know a variety of options and
you know most probably we will be
looking up in the demo because we will
be logging into the the portal and
i will be showing you on the different
options that we have so there is a lot
of mix and match okay trust me because
you have your windows servers with your
sql databases installed you have your
windows servers with your oracle
databases installed
okay and you also have your um
okay so
we have um
[Music]
a lot of mix and matches that you can
actually perform
right
all right and um the next thing uh what
we see is your app services so the
second popular things i mean i'm not
going to read them as one two three
first but uh and just as our flow
so one of the uh other popular products
is your app service
where in which you can create the mobile
apps from any platform and from any
device
so
and after that you have your sql
databases and trust me it is like
you know it's very vast on the sql
databases end and
there are so many things that you can
actually do
um
so when it comes to the sql databases
basically uh they actually speak like a
database as a service where you can
take a database and use that or
integrate it uh with your
okay if it's gonna be integrated uh you
know you can integrate it with your
hybrid of models your private uh you can
actually create your own private cloud
uh in the public front so there's a lot
of things that you can do and from the
sql end
and uh one of the things is on the
storage uh we have the durable and the
mass massive scalable cloud storages
so
what i would say uh again uh by default
uh we all are using a one type of
storage right so one drive or
the live uh yeah i mean the one drive or
what we are using right now is again
from
the azure platform and uh yeah and they
have a massive
storage which can be easily scalable and
also you can actually verify uh
the consistency of the data it is always
the same across
and you have your uh the cloud services
where you can actually
create a highly available infinite
scalable cloud applications and you have
a lot of apis
okay and your
nosql document database uh again you
have a variety of services on the
databases end
you have your sql and you have your uh
the nosql databases
and uh one of the major things is your
active directory uh which is actually
helping us a lot with uh the hybrid
model of cloud computing right now
where uh we see your integrations of
you know and uh integrations of your
on-premises and uh enabling your uh
single sign-ons and we have something
called as uh
zero auth r2 that is again one of the
common protocols or one of the terms
which has been used across different uh
providers for authentications
and uh again uh one of the most uh
common thing that is or the most uh
reliable product or the popular product
what we have is here
uh the backups
so backups to the cloud uh which is
going to be uh
a trend right now so we see uh these are
a couple of products and apart from this
you have a various list um more than
like 50 plus uh one of the products and
which are frequently updated
um and uh you can actually look up into
the you know you can actually um
look up on the azure portals and uh you
can get uh you know what the new things
which they are coming up and
again on the demo part now we might
actually look into it and a couple of uh
the azure components um
okay um
so again whenever we are speaking about
our data layer you have your uh the
storages and again uh the different
types of uh storages what we have is
your on the normal drives your blob
storages
where uh the data has been uh segregated
into different things your tables on the
sequels your queues and your caching
and on the sql azure you have your
stream lights reporting in the databases
the computing part you have your
infrastructures
and
yes you can actually earn big data
uh azure is doing a really good thing on
the big data and there's a lot of
integrations and a lot of things which
happen on the big data right now
and uh when it comes to your network you
have your you know the access controls
uh where you
you can
restrict or provide access to the users
in a different way i mean the group of
users and uh you can actually create
your traffic or your virtual networks
okay
and uh on your client layer it's all
about like how you are going to access
all of these services what we discussed
it's like you know maybe your pcs your
tablets your browser even from xbox uh
and uh
again how you want to integrate uh
because you have your on date
on premises databases and the
integration of that
and uh
uh and again um
we have just you know just a brief about
a couple of services uh what we see we
have our virtual machines uh and again
uh we just need to create deploy and
manage virtual machines in the other
platform the websites uh we can actually
use or create a new websites or we can
migrate
our existing business websites onto the
cloud okay
and then uh we have our uh you know the
cloud services uh where in which you can
uh build and deploy uh aha
and scalable applications with a lower
administration task and you have your of
the mobile services which are used for
building and deploying the apps and the
storing data for your mobile devices
and uh
okay and we have your network services
uh
and with that network systems we have
your virtual network
okay and uh with that uh we can actually
treat uh as an extension to your
on-premises data center by creating that
virtual network
and with that what happens is you can
actually build or scale
your environment and again one of the
major reasons for us to go with the
virtual network is to
have the hybrid model of the cloud
computing and even as per the recent um
yeah i mean uh even as for the recent
service of from right scale in 2016
april just in this month
uh we do see that there is a trend uh
which is increasing on the hybrid cloud
model
so uh to actually uh you know help us
out a lot on it um
we do see uh you know
uh you know right now there's an
increase on the virtual network and we
have the traffic manager
so
it actually helps us in uh
it actually routes the application
traffic uh uses who is actually using
the application to windows azure data
centers
so uh again uh we are just discussing
about uh
a couple of network services uh
and we have our uh okay and we have our
data services in which again as i told
you uh there is a lot of things on the
databases you have your relational
microsoft databases
that's the sql databases and along with
that you have your under nosql and using
your rest apis or using your blog
storages the data can be managed
and uh you have your business analytics
uh
again uh
using your again the reportings and
analysis services okay and one of the
very interesting part is your hd insight
which actually helps us in providing the
apache hadoop solution
which can be on the cloud so as i told
you like you know um there is a lot of
things which you can done on uh azure
platform because there's a lot of
services now it depends upon
what type of a service that i am looking
for
and what we can actually uh you know
uh go ahead and uh
you know again it's very completely
based upon our requirements
and uh
the on the
continuation of our data services
other in the caching because it actually
helps us to speed up our cloud-based
applications and it is helping out in
our
database a load
and uh
again the backups uh
you have your backups
between uh two different sites you can
actually have your manual backups your
automated your offsite backups again
there is something called as your
disaster recovery as a service uh
so you have your disaster recovery
services where in which you can actually
um genome
have your servers been replicated to a
different site uh geographically and uh
uh trust me uh what happens is uh on the
geographical or the different zones what
we have
so the things will vary if it is
geographically a different location
sometimes azure will actually do it or
sometimes not because of the data
protection and the loss which will come
into the picture
and um
again we have our recovery managers and
we have your hyper-v recovery manager so
it actually helps us in protecting our
business critical services
okay and
uh again the recovery of our system
center 2012 are the private clouds
all right and uh we have our app
services uh
okay and uh on the media services it
will actually help us to build the
workflows for your creation management
and the distribution of
the azure public cloud and other
messagings yes uh you know you can
actually have your apps connected across
your different environments
and the notification
hubs provides your high scalable and
across platform push notification
infrastructures and again uh for any of
your running um you know especially your
apps running on your mobile devices
and a couple of more on the app services
what we have uh we have your uh the
bizstock again it provides an end to end
solution of your uh enterprise
application integrations
uh again integrating with your hybrid uh
services there and
the active directory
uh it's uh basically for your idm uh
identity management
and access control capabilities uh for
your cloud applications so
you can restrict uh the access
of it
and uh we have our multi-factor
authentication uh for enhanced uh level
of securities and everything
uh we do provide and i mean azure
provides an additional layer of
authentications
so that you know it is both secure on
the on-premises and as well as on our
the cloud applications
so
the main portal or the web gui right now
what we will be using okay and uh since
microsoft has like two different portals
uh which we will look uh in just a
couple of minutes
uh
give me one quick minute please uh all
right and i just had like uh one of the
questions from uh one of our team
members uh chetan uh would like to hear
on a logic app service uh chetan uh what
i would suggest you is uh you know maybe
if the time permits definitely i will
look into it uh if not uh you can always
use our uh the simply talk forum
in which uh
i'm sorry uh okay so in which uh you can
actually uh
okay uh you can post that question and i
will be uh updating uh you on that so um
i'm just going to uh give you that url
because right now um we are
having a small webinar for one hour and
that too we had some issues in the start
so yeah i mean you know so maybe i can
uh
if time permits yeah
okay
all right so uh i'm so sorry but again
i'm going to send you this particular
link uh use our simply talk community
so that uh
if any case if you have anything that
you want to know more uh please post it
under the cloud or computing server
of sector of the forum and i will be
able to address you
i have uh one more question uh d raj um
do you provide microsoft azure training
program
uh now dealers are not as of now uh but
we are actually planning on to it so uh
we will keep you posted on how you know
when it is going to be available but uh
uh we have uh on uh exiting cloud
computing which is going to be the basic
fundamental of how the cloud and how
what cloud computing does
and uh so uh i mean nothing on the azure
platform but we are actually planning on
it and we will get back to you on it
um
we have another question from uh rose uh
will the training be uploaded in your
youtube channel uh rose frankly um
cannot uh you know assure you anything
as of now because i'm
not sure if this will it is gonna be
uploaded but uh
i'll do my best and i will be updating
you on you know if this can be accessed
uh from elsewhere
all right
and uh because right now when we look on
the azure plot azure platform uh we have
um now the current or the new portal
what we say is uh it's called as an
azure resource manager
so uh let us quickly see a couple of uh
you know the benefits of the azure
platform
so uh from the other you know the
resource platforms you have you can
actually
deploy
okay all the resources as a group and
not as an individual thing
and you can actually group up them uh as
one container which is again very easy
for us at even at a time of your
billings and
deployment
and other benefit is you can deploy your
solutions throughout the development
cycle and
again they can be deployed in a
consistent state
um
it actually gives us and declarative
templates to define our deployments
and uh again uh
we can actually you know uh with this
arm we can actually define the
dependencies
between the various resources and
once it has been done they all can be
deployed up properly
and one of the major things
that we have is your role based access
control are back
which is again for your enhanced level
of securities and
one of the good things that we have is
you can actually tag
now you are actually created your
resource group and then you can actually
tag those resources
and so that you know you can actually um
you know verify it even the time of your
billing or to manage them it's much
easier
all right and you can clarify the
billing for your organization by viewing
your rolled up cost for the entire group
or the group of resources sharing the
same tag
and uh just an overview of
the
new portal
okay and
we have our the resource groups resource
group is nothing but it is a container
uh which
holds all the related uh application
resources for an application so if you
have a software that needs to be built
and you need a certain type of your
operating system a platform
and a couple of more resources for us to
build that software so you can bundle
all together and so that is going to be
your resource group and what is your
resource provider uh it's a service that
supplies the resources you can deploy
and manage through your resource manager
and
you have your template deployment uh we
can just create all of your templates uh
using json uh again you see a lot of
integrations that has happened with json
you can automate
a lot of process uh
uh using your uh you know the json
scripting
and uh
again uh using that particular you can
define or your own deployment and your
templates which can be used for
deploying configuration of any of your
applications
and we have your tags
so as we discussed you can actually tag
uh your all of your resources according
to your requirements and again uh it is
much easier for us to you know manage
them and even for your billing purpose
and uh we have our access control uh
access control again as i told you it is
again uh one of the very good feature uh
that we have right now because
on the access control uh you can
actually use or integrate your existing
uh active directories on premise active
directory and uh along with that uh it
natively integrates with uh oauth um
this is again a mechanism where in which
you will be authenticated uh by our
email address i'm just giving it as an
example right now so on using your oauth
it's again going to be like a single
sign-on on one of the things i mean on
this platform platforms
so you can uh integrate them and
provide the access across the different
resources that you have uh one of the
other things what we see from the azure
resource model i mean the other i'm
sorry resource azure
i'm sorry azure resource manager okay uh
it's going to be uh
you know you can actually create your
customized policies
okay and uh you can manage uh all of
your resources based upon you know the
customizations uh that we have in
place all right so uh let us quickly uh
see a quick demo and before that i have
like a one question here uh vijay uh
okay uh what is the different uh
okay uh okay uh you know the
company cloud essentials and the cloud
plus uh they give you an overview about
uh you know what cloud computing is all
about and what are the other
requirements and uh again we will be
discussing something about the
essentials what we have and the
different types of the deployment models
the underlying technologies and how the
cloud came into the existence and uh
okay so there are a couple of things uh
that actually know they speak about so
uh they are not specific to again this
is a vendor neutral courses what we have
from exin and com
these are a vendor neutral so they don't
speak about a specific vendor
okay they are a completely vendor
neutral certification of the courses to
give you more idea about how the things
work and what the things are
okay and uh give it one quick minute uh
i'm just going to uh you know share um
that screen
uh for
the small demo all right
okay i'm sorry for that so uh this was
uh you know the azure portal in which i
was telling you and uh this is the old
azure portal what we have so in the old
azure portal
managing of the resources
there is a lot of difference again and
you can actually uh look on microsoft
website for the
differences that we have from the old
portal and
the new arm so if you look up on the
website details
of the web url you see it's it's going
to be like manage windows azure.com and
it says portal.azure.com
so this is uh the arm model on which we
are discussing right now
okay so as we told you uh the first
thing uh what we have is uh
your uh the resource group on to the
left um
okay and uh as you told i know we can
actually uh create
your all resources you can combine all
of those resources you can add okay you
can actually recreate uh you know um
all of your uh i mean the resource
groups uh let us just give it a few
minutes okay so now i can actually uh
give a name and again
i have an option to
you know select on which data center all
of my resources will be located from
so i can opt all of them
and i can actually create a you know a
resource group out of it and
based upon that uh you know i can
actually combine so again uh it will be
easy for me on
the billing and managing of all of my
resources
okay and uh we have something called as
your or uh
again after i create uh the resource
group i will be able to manage all of my
uh resources here uh and uh it's
location what is the subscription type
so i'll tell you uh you know the
subscription type will actually change
uh
and
one of the reasons for that being uh we
will be discussing on the pricing model
so if you if you're right because right
now my account is on uh the pay as you
go model so i've been using that model
there
all right and
after that uh you have your app services
so these are just
a few services
so if you see your active directory uh
all right i clicked on all resources
okay i haven't have so
all right let me browse your your all of
your api apps your app management
services so these are
a few services what we have from the
azure platform right now
so you can actually use
any of these particular services
all right and
now this is completely based upon our
requirements if you want again uh we
actually spoke about uh
okay and uh you know where we have your
uh
all of your uh you know and uh
all of your services and um
uh support uh you asked me about that uh
the radius cache so here you have uh so
uh this can be actually accessed as one
of the services from the azure platform
okay
and uh
all right so um these are just uh
a very small glimpse of what we can
actually do here and uh you have your
virtual machines your virtual networks
that you can integrate your on-premises
and
to your cloud so you can create uh your
the public cloud and as i told you uh
you know we can actually add your own
sql databases uh
so anything on the microsoft proprietary
uh it's it's you know it's a piece of
cake and it can be it's all now
depending upon how you want to integrate
so
uh what i usually suggest is you need to
have
you need to have a proper design of what
is our requirement where the data will
be stored and how you can actually
access it so once you have the proper
design
managing and creating all of the
resources is really very easy and even
that can be accessed so again if i'm
looking up on taking up the sql database
all right so i can just go on the sql
database i can actually select what type
of a database all right and again i have
an option
on the pricing uh there are things that
actually change
all right
so
again uh we will look up on the pricing
uh later on because there is a lot of
things and especially on the collect on
the collision where you want to collate
all of them
and uh as i discussed uh like you know
we have uh on the virtual machine you
have both windows and a non-windows
virtual machine
and out of which uh you have
okay
you can actually
use
uh these virtual machines and also you
have more virtual machines which are
coming up with inbuilt databases as i
told you earlier we have your uh the sql
your oracle databases and uh
again um
so this is just an overview about what
operating systems so as i told you uh
azure as a very vast options for us so
now it depends upon uh like what is our
requirement and
what uh we need to plan for so um again
uh if you are if you want to learn or if
you could if you want to get your hands
on on the azure platform
uh it's actually a free uh
for 30 days
okay so once you create your account uh
you would be by default using your
hotmail account and once you actually
use
your hotmail account
you can go ahead and
you know subscribe and eventually it
will be asking for you for your credit
card information and once you have your
credit card information
all right so once you have your uh you
know the credit card informations you
will be able to uh access and uh you uh
if you're in india you will be getting
like 12 000 rupees for free so that you
can actually navigate across and uh you
know perform your test
okay and uh right now uh this is my
other subscription which is actually uh
pay as you go so whenever i use i only
pay for what is being required all right
so uh this is just on uh you know a
small game from how
the microsoft uh azure actually and the
you know the platform that we have and
how you can actually group all of
the microsoft azure services as one and
again uh based upon which location you
want to group those locations and
everything that can be done here okay
simple uh overview of it
and uh let me quickly get back our uh
the presentation
all right
and uh as i told you like uh the things
are different on the azure brand uh you
know the pricing uh because uh one of
the things that you have is your the
most common your pay as you go and even
my account was on your
pay as you go
the subscriptions and uh you have your
prepaid subscriptions so there are like
seven different types and uh you can get
more detail about
the pricing on uh you know both of these
uh
links what we have so an example again
this is from the azure
website uh just for your app services
it's again starting from free every
month
and you have your
virtual machines again now that depends
upon your configuration all right it's
not 781 it's like again there is a lot
of configuration you have your tiers of
a virtual machine where you have your uh
you know if it is a shared model your
processing which has been shared your
disk which has been shared so
now uh this information or okay this
information will actually change on
what type of
virtual machine you are picking up and
again if that is a windows virtual
machine or a non-windows
and for your sql databases as i told you
now that depends upon what type of sql
database you are looking up
okay so as we saw the different services
now the pricing will change and uh we
have like seven types of offerings from
the azure right now you have your pay as
you go your prepaid your microsoft again
you can actually get it from the
reseller you have your enterprise
agreements for the big organizations and
your compute option your hybrid use
benefit
and your enterprise uh agreement
okay and
uh again whenever we are speaking about
uh
all of the azure
again anybody whenever you're talking
about any cloud platform always the
major thing is on your um
the compliances okay so whenever we
speak about your compliances we actually
go with the certifications so azure is
uh certified from the cloud security
alliances uh again uh the complete list
can be accessed from uh the link which
has been pasted here
and
you have because every region as i told
you every geographical region the things
will vary on the compliances and that is
one of the reasons
why we have the data centers across the
globe
so these are just a couple of uh you
know the certified uh certifications of
the azure platform
and uh okay uh let me come to the
questions now
all right uh
all right and uh can you paste the
pricing okay uh super give me one quick
minute uh let me actually paste
you want only the pricing okay
all right and uh for the pricing um
i have pasted that link okay that is for
the pricing
and uh if you want to get some more
details now as i told you the difference
on the pricing uh is completely upon
what are the requirements that we have
so this is for your virtual machine
and on
is aix and hp uf supported unfortunately
uh we don't have aix and hp ux right now
on azure uh we only have uh you know the
windows and the non-windows especially
on centos ubuntu and uh red hat so i
mean that major players uh so we don't
have any aix or hp ux uh in the azure
front right now
uh uh let us see uh
let me rephrase yup i mean uh aix hpx
and sun solaris they are not supported
on the cloud front i agree completely
agree with you on the public front
but if we look on uh different cloud
service providers
uh there are
i mean uh there are at least one or two
companies who actually give us uh hp ux
uh because they actually give us your
complete uh you know the physical server
so that can be taken as a service so
there are but again uh they're not on
the big names
okay like uh azure aws or
name any big names you won't find them
on the big name cloud service providers
but yeah
but yes uh we have uh one of the service
provider who actually
provides uh you know uh hp ux
uh chittenden i'm going to unmute you
online
yeah uh hi chittan uh i have admitted
your line
uh chetan uh you have a question and uh
i i mute uh you know you can actually
all right
okay so um i have chetan's question how
can simply learn help uh learn azure
uh chicken actually uh we are planning
to start up on the azure platform so uh
right now we have uh various uh courses
uh i mean um the vendor neutral courses
of
exin and
just know the comptia
so we are coming up on uh specifically
on the vendor specifics and
uh we are uh you know going to be uh
launching the training sessions uh uh
very soon so as of now i don't have any
epa for it uh but definitely uh we can
actually keep you posted on it
dredge has a question like would you be
forwarding the ppt to all the registered
emails um geerage um
not sure but let me check uh with
our team uh
okay
uh i'm jim just give me one quick note
i'm checking on the dream
okay and uh
if you want to actually get your hands
on on azure platform uh please feel free
because uh it is actually uh once you
log in it will be asking for your credit
card information for the registrations
and uh you will not be charged
it's gonna direct a dollar uh
just for the initial subscriptions and
after that uh you will be able to access
the azure platform for 30 days
so
you can actually you know try out um
or use your azure i mean you know try
out the various options that we have
and uh
you know you can actually get
familiarized on the azure platform
uh
shaitan's question is any links where i
can see use cases implemented uh
leveraging azure platform
uh children there are like so many of
them uh if you look up on the azure
platform i mean like the azure website
itself if you go to uh
the top fortune 500 companies they have
like so many cases you know the
case studies what they have
so
i mean uh house of different companies
are actually uh you know benefited on
that one so if you're actually looking
for something uh specific on that one um
maybe you know i can actually uh get
back to you so if you can please uh you
know help me post uh that question on
our cloud uh
so then uh one small request uh if you
can actually uh post that question on
our the simply talk forum uh definitely
i will get you all this information
you are welcome because as of now i
don't have anything handy but uh
definitely
uh so let's see uh so this course will
be based on arm or combination of cloud
services or arm
most probably it would be on the air
because
right now uh
the you know the major benefits that we
see on our arm side is uh
you know especially on the you know
managing or grouping those
resources what we have
and also on your authentications and the
security purposes where you can
integrate a lot of things
so
we would be looking upon the arm front
because even microsoft is
actually you know uh help um he's asking
us to uh
to go on with the air because it has
actually come up with uh
so many features that we have
uh
seriously okay uh arm is equivalent to
vpc uh let me rephrase
uh
arm uh is uh the portal that we logged
in okay uh this is our azure resource
manager
so
your uh vpc is gonna be your virtual
private cloud again which is one of the
different services and you have
something called as your uh you know the
cloud services
which can be defined
so arm is just the way or the dashboard
that we see or usually we call this as a
dashboard
the cloud front
so
okay arm is uh the dashboard that we
have been speaking about uh if there is
anything uh
related to let me know
uh today why one must prefer azure or uh
or aws or the other cloud services um
i'm actually speaking about uh azure
right now
okay and i'll give you an oversight okay
so
now that depends upon the company okay
whenever we say which cloud service
provider to go with okay
uh then what i would suggest is that you
know uh trial each one of them okay
because everyone gives you a trial
period all the cloud service providers
so use that particular uh you know the
trial period
uh access or you know test your
applications or you know do have your
deployments and everything done and see
how it actually meets your business
requirements on your sls the compliances
the regulations the pricing sector
okay and then you actually opt for um
one of the cloud service providers
okay so
i mean like uh there are a couple of
things uh which are good on one end and
which are not that good
yeah
yeah because it belongs to microsoft
uh
yeah i mean from tilasia again thanks as
i'm aws uh guide uh will there be any
comparison about the products in azure
while doing the course so is it
so it's easy to pick the azure
uh let's see if you are comparing uh
azure to aws if you look up uh you know
maybe the technologies what they are
using is a bit different
okay if you look up on the aws on the
console and
the way it's been designed
so there would be uh you know the
technological differences but if you are
looking onto the logical way of
accessing or you know the way it works
so the logically it is a similar way so
it will be like very easy for us to go
and uh work on azure if you have a
knowledge on aws it will be like much
easier for us to understand on the azure
platform
and then shaker is it possible to test
vpn between azure cloud and our data
center in trial period
okay uh one good question d rich um the
sony thunder shaker
uh frankly i never tested uh the vpns
but uh definitely feel free
uh frankly i never uh no i never really
tested uh you know if you can actually
uh you know
have a vpn and so
i mean you have a free account right so
you can actually try it out um
so uh if you don't know if you have any
questions okay please uh you know use of
the community forum uh you can actually
paste uh your
any questions that you have so i'm just
actually again uh
giving you that link so just in case if
you need uh some more information or
some more clarity on
how things work please feel free use our
community forum have your questions and
we will be responding back to you all
right
and uh thank you all for taking your
time and attending this uh webinar and i
hope it has given you some insight about
what azure is all about
you